>> Tucker: CONTINUING TO WATCH
EVERYTHING THAT IS HAPPENING ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THE PRESIDENT WILL DELIVER HIS
FIRST STATE OF THE UNION DRASZ.
EVEN AFTER THE SPEECH, CONGRESS
WILL ARGUE ON THE RELEASE OF THE
FOUR- PAGE MEMO COMPILE WOULD BY
DEVON NUNEZ.
WE HAVE THE DEMOCRAT CONGRESSMAN
REPRESENTING RHODE ISLAND.
THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
SO AT THE CORE OF THE MEMO,
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW IS IN THERE,
SOMETHING WE KNOW IS TRUE.
WHICH IS THAT OBAMA OFFICIALS
ASKED FOR A FISA WARRANT ON THE
GROUND THAT HE WAS A FOREIGN
AGENCY AND SPY FOR PUTIN'S
GOVERNMENT.
DO YOU THINK THAT CARTER PAGE
WAS A SPY FOR PUTIN'S
GOVERNMENT?
>> I HAVE READ THE NUNEZ MEMO
CONTENTS.
IT WAS A MEMO PREPARED BY A
PARTISAN DEVON NUNEZ.
HE WAS SO PARTIS AN HE WAS
THE DOCUMENTS.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY PARTISANS
ARE IN CONGRESS?
>> IN IS NOT AN INTELLIGENCE
AND HE RECUED HIMSELF.
AND HE PURPORTS TO SUMMARIZE THE
DOCUMENTS HE NEVER READ.
>> Tucker: I DEPARTMENT ASK YOU
ABOUT NUBEZ OR THE DOCUMENTS.
BULLPEN THE INFORMATION THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO ALL AMERICANS.
MENT OBAMA ADMINISTRATION MADE
THE CASE THAT THE MAN WAS A SPY.
I CAN'T COMMENT.
>> Tucker: I KNOW THAT.
>> I HAVE READ BOTH MEMOS.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T NEED TO
HAVE READ THE MEMO TO COMMENT ON
THAT?
>> YOU CAN'T COMMENT.
>> Tucker: THE NEW YORK TIMES
>> I AM TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE
MEMO DOES.
TUCK TUG WE KNOW THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION ARGUE WOULD THAT
TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
>> I CAN'T COMMENT ON THAT
PARTICULAR.
WE HAVE CERTAINLY IN THE WE HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT RUSSIAN IFRNT
FERRANCE.
>> Tucker: I AM SURE THERE IS A
LOT OF POLL TECHES.
BUT AS AN AMERICAN.
I DON'T WANT.
>> TO INTERFERE.
>> Tucker: I AM NOT TRYING TO.
BUT THE OTHER CONCERN IS THAT
THE GOVERNMENT MAY BE SPIES ON
PEOPLE FOR ELECTRIC TO DISPUTE
IT IF YOU WILL.
>> I WILL TELL YOU THIS, I TAKE
ANY ALLIES GO I SPENT MY DREAR
AND DID THE DIAGRAM ON THE
SPYING.
>> I CAN'T ANSWER THAT.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU CONCERNED
>> I WOULD BE CONCERNED IF IT
WAS NOT FOLLOWED BY THE FISA
COURT.
>> Tucker: NO ONE IS SUGGESTING
THAT THE FEDERAL JUDGE OR WHO
IT PAMLEAM HARRIS THING.
>> I HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE FBI WHO TAKE L
>> NO, DON'T ASK COMBHES.
BUT THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS.
IT SETS THE STAGE FOR THE
TOMORROWATION EAR
>>Y AMY
>> BUT WHY IS IT, TUCKER, THEN,
WHEN THE GIT REEVERY SINGLE (YOU